c'est une assez vieilles constante dans
notre pays qu'à un moment donné une
partie de la population parce qu'elle
sent effectivement que nous sommes dans
une situation compliquée se disent
finalement le dernier recours c'est
l'armée et oui après tout pourquoi pas
que je me souviens qu'il ya déjà
quelques quelques dizaines d'années
il y avait dans les journaux des
tribunes disant si ça continue il faudra
y envoyer l'armée
une fois qu'on a dit ça
est ce que finalement mis au pied du mur
et voyant la réalité d'une intervention
militaire et la totalité de ceux qui ont
répondu positivement à ce sondage serait
heureux du résultat j'en suis absolument
pas persuadé parce qu'encore une fois ce
qui manque dans tout cela c'est de dire
qu'on n'a pas épuisé toutes les voies de
recours
on n'a pas épuisé toutes les voies de
recours parce que le politique peut se
saisir davantage se saisir mieux de la
situation parce qu'il ya quand même la
démocratie qui permet d'exprimer un vote
parce qu'on a parlé tout à l'heure du
volet policier de la répression des
incivilités la délinquance paye
également les questions du volet
judiciaire sur lequel il ya me
semble-t-il beaucoup de discussions à
avoir donc je crois qu'il faut prendre
de ce sondage avec énormément de
pincettes
ce putsch ne ne prend pas voilà parce
qu'on a aujourd'hui une société dans
laquelle on a les réseaux sociaux dans
lesquels on à la société civile etc l on
a naturellement des des contre-pouvoirs
et il me semble véritablement que les
français n'accepteraient ces deux
solutions pour devrais je dire voyant le
matin quand ils se réveillent l'armée
dans la rue il ne l'accepterai
véritablement qu'en cas de délitement
absolue bien au-delà de ce que nous
connaissons
ce qui ne veut pas dire que la situation
soit rôle
[Musique]